اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره مرحبا بكم عشرات الشهداء في غارات
اسرائيليه على انحاء قطع غزه واحتجاجات
مستمره لاهالي المحتجزين الاسرائيليين
تطالب بتحريرهم عبر صفقه تبادل وسائل
اعلام اسرائيليه قالت ان مجلس الحرب يبحث
منحا جديدا لصفقه تهدف الى اعاده
المختطفين في حين اكدت حماس رفضها لاي
مفاوضات تبادل مالم توقف الحرب وتجدون
المزيد من اخبار حرب غزه في رابط التعليق
الاول الاف الاشخاص يفرون من مدينه ود
مدني وسط السودان ثاني اكبر مدينه في
البلاد وذلك بسبب اشتباكات اندلعت بين
قوات الدعم السريع والجيش السوداني الذي
يسيطروا على المدينه منذ بدء القتال بين
الطرفين بعد مسيره استمرت سته عقود في
العمل العام الكويت تودع اميرها الراحل
الشيخ نوافل احمد الصباح حيث شارك امير
الكويت الجديد الشيخ مشعل الاحمد الجابر
الصباح في صلاه الجنازه على الفقيد في
مسجد بلال بن رباح بمنطقه
الصديق المنظمه الدوليه للهجره تعلن مقتل
اكثر من 60 مهاجرا بينهم نساء واطفال اثر
غرق قاربهم قباله سواحل ليبيا المنظمه
قالت ان القارب الذي كان يقل نحو 86 شخصا
غادر من مدينه زواره باتجاه السواحل
الشماليه للبحر المتوسط فيما تم نقل
الناجين الى العاصمه طرابلس الى
اللقاء